first of all uh you look fantastic how
do you feel
thank you i feel i feel great i feel
i've been feeling a lot of things
recently a lot of emotions leading up to
what is going on with this release and
um i feel
i feel a personal release i think myself
what is the what's the one emotion that
sort of keeps coming back
i i think it it feels like i've finally
like
let something off my chest and in a
positive
way i mean i've been so excited about
this music for the last
over a year now and to have
something that i've known existed for so
long finally out there and to see
you know have people be able to give me
responses and what they think about it
and everything is
it's great so what what did you going
into this because you
this has been something that it seems
like has been inside of you for a long
time
but when it actually comes down to
putting it together it comes
it seems like it was about what do i
want to say and what did you want to say
with this project i
have spent the last 10 years trying to
go through the process go through the
process of growing up
which is hard enough as it is and i
think
with the way that i had my start at 13
and
kind of immediately having an outlet to
say something and not knowing at
all who i was or what i wanted to say
and
all of that um i've always felt like i
was catching up with myself
and and with what people thought about
me and with this project
and what has happened over the last
couple of years and the confidence that
i've built within myself
i finally feel like i
know and have proven to myself that i
can do this
and i'm so proud of the music that i
have made with everybody who helped me
put this project together
um from co-writers to producing it it
feels
like my voice and it feels like i've
found the thing
that i had missed
for so so long did you
did you flip between a desire to prove
something to
other people and then it switched to
proving something to yourself
i was always trying to prove something
to myself i mean even
before friday was even
a blip um or a thought
i i came from you know a background of
feeling like i needed to have really
high standards for myself and
even as a kid and i
i think i've always been trying to prove
prove to myself that i could do it even
more to anybody else and and finally i
i think i've made a little bit of ground
on on that
that journey um also uh happy early
birthday
thanks are you
ever are you ever shocked because i'm
shocked when when you hear people
talk about you they they seem
overwhelmingly
overwhelmed with how much you've changed
in 10 years without realizing that 13 to
23
most people tend to change a whole lot
you would hope so i mean it would be
really bizarre if i had it
but does that ever shock you at all like
what are they what do they expect to
happen like the expectations
are people have you in a box and some
people
want you to grow and become something
else and other people don't
yeah i mean gosh everybody has such
different expectations of everybody else
and we're always and i do this myself
too casting my own judgment or choosing
not to on kind of everybody that i come
across
and whether i can help it or not and um
i i mean i've definitely lived these
past 10 years
literally every single day of them and
um and
it's been you know i i've very much felt
a lot of the growth uh through the hard
way
a long time just as we all kind of do
and i guess you know
i i can't understand the
the fact that everybody is is doing that
and living their lives and a lot has
changed over the past 10 years
in general uh and
even the way that i look at you know the
internet and and and everything as a
whole in 2011 to now
um i i look through it with a different
lens than i would have at the time
you know even just regardless of the
fact that i was 13.
can you guys hear that sorry yeah it's
fine i can put i can put headphones in
if i need to
okay you know what can you maybe you
should can you throw headphones in real
quick
this damn street okay
can you hear me yes i can hear you the
car's still going but oh yeah it's good
it's good okay yeah we're good cool
um so between your last couple of
singles and then getting into
um worth it for the feeling it really
sounds like you've gone through
some stuff
yeah is that safe to say there was
there was love and then there wasn't and
then there was and maybe there wasn't
again
and it just seems like you've gone
through some stuff
yeah i mean i think now that i'm
starting to talk to people about this
project and more and more people are
hearing it uh
it's just dawned on me the i guess
amount of honesty that i put into this
project and how many people
know exactly what's been going on in my
world which is okay it's exactly
why this project exists and um
yeah i mean i i think
uh gosh as i've as i've learned to write
over the past you know few years of my
life
the point of view that i've had has
obviously changed a lot and
the i guess variety that i can write
about has changed a lot because i've had
a lot more experience
um in my life i mean i still am
just 23 almost 24 but you know
i've started to experience my first
goals at love and and really
meaningful heartbreak and how that
affects myself and and
learning to recognize how that affects
the other person and i think that's
something that we all go through i mean
i obviously came out as queer last year
and a lot of this project is very
heavily queer and
it's about a relationship that meant
so much to me and and the person that i
am now and
um this project would be nothing if it
wasn't on it honest
um there's so much when it comes to uh
feelings and i'm wondering
when you when you're in the moment and
you want to put everything down on track
um you know what love is like and you
know what relationships are like is
there ever any hesitation
to put it all out there just because
there's the odd chance that it may work
out in the end
i mean that was this entire project is i
wrote some of the songs
um from a pretty bitter perspective
before getting back together with a
person and then in the end it just
didn't really work out
but um i don't know i don't think there
is hesitation because
that all at the end of the day like
this project for me and the writing of
it was a coping mechanism
and it it was more than a coping
mechanism i mean it really
allowed me to to see my thoughts
literally on paper and and understand
them in a way i couldn't have
um it was extremely therapeutic and
i try not to think about how
someone you know that the song is about
might take it
because at the end of the day one a lot
of people
love a song about them and i know that
this person
who this project is really about kind of
loves that it's about them anymore
i mean i would love if the song was
about me and that's all part of the fun
um and we you know everyone moves on
everyone moves past things and if
anything it's like
a little stamp of what that time was
like for
you know me and not in that point of my
life um coming out as
as queer last year you have been so
incredibly welcomed into
that community and the organizations and
being recognized and praised
what was that like for you because did
it feel like sort of coming home
in a way that they were that these
people were just there
sort of like waiting with open arms i
mean
i had no idea what to expect um
leading up to it but like you said
people have just been
so incredibly welcoming and supportive
to me
and uh i mean that was more than
anything i could have
hoped for and it just you know
i i definitely feel
i guess a sense of coming home in a way
because i i felt like i guess i could
just really
allow a part of myself to exist openly
um without you know kind of
having to hide it at all so many people
in my audience and i have so many
incredible fans who are queer themselves
and have
shared their stories and i i almost feel
like i owe it to them
to share mine in a way because one i
feel comfortable to do so and i hope
that it allows for you know
some sense of representation or
validation for them in the end
um friday has lived for so long 10 years
now
when you started noticing it becoming
something
different when you started noticing it
becoming a drag queen karaoke anthem
when you started seeing it pop up on
places where they weren't goofing on it
they were
sort of respecting it in a way
that it makes people feel good like it's
become this
thing and it's still with you it's still
so much a part of you what's your
relationship
with friday 10 years later
the dialogues changed a lot and
i am so grateful for
just even people who will send me a
little message asking for
you know a video for them to show their
teacher who plays a song for
their class every friday i think it's
really
it's really sweet that that song in the
end could bring people
even just the most simple sense of joy
that
maybe it was originally intended to and
um i mean i i've definitely
been through many stages with my
relationship with friday and i've tried
to be
open about that but at this point now i
mean especially with dropping the remix
this year
i i have so much love for for that song
and what that experience brought me in
the end
because even though it wasn't always
easy it definitely was
not easy um it you know i wouldn't be
the person that i am without what i
learned